[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction de tv
fils voici les principaux titres de ce
16 mars 2017
saint cyr l'école saint germain en laye
en 35 minutes c'est l'enjeu du chantier
de la ligne 13 les travaux se
poursuivent nous faisons le point
le marché international des
professionnels de l'immobilier se tient
actuellement à cannes l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines entend séduire
pour attirer de grands groupes et puis
le 25 mars
issy paris hand rencontrera à brest au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
rencontre choc et pour battre un record
d'affluence les joueuses assure la
promotion de l'événement et notamment
vous le voyez dans les écoles auprès des
plus jeunes le mipim c'est le grand
marché international de l'immobilier il
se déroule en ce moment et jusqu'au 17
mars à cannes une délégation de saint
quentin en yvelines est présente sur ce
salon pour mettre en avant les forces du
territoire entre ses 4,6 millions de
mètres carrés à disposition et un
environnement fiscal annoncé attractif
écoutez le président de l'agglomération
joint par téléphone par haussmann
vandeurzen l'écouté moi depuis que je
suis arrivé hier matin j'ai des
rendez-vous de meyer par demi heure je
participe à des conférences sur les
grands investissements qui sont les
nôtres avec les autres territoires
français et donc moi le plus important
c'est que notre territoire soit le plus
attractif possible et je peux vous dire
que de nombreux promoteurs deux d'entre
eux un féticheur sont tout à fait
déterminés pour venir travailler avec
nous à saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
l'enjeu du mipim de ce marché
international de l'immobilier c'est à
retrouver dans le 7-8 échos a consulté
notamment sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile dès à présent
initialement appelé tangentielle ouest
le tram 13 express rentre dans sa phase
active les travaux préparatoires ont
débuté sur plusieurs sites et notamment
à saint cyr l'école
à terme cette nouvelle ligne permettra
de rejoindre à saint germain en laye en
une trentaine de minutes pour des
travaux estimé à un peu plus de 300
millions d'euros détails de ce projet
avec nicolas qu'ils aillent vite
nicolas landry les premiers travaux ont
pris finalement cinq mois de retard le
tram très express commencent à voir le
jour plus de dix ans après le lancement
du projet les travaux dits préparatoires
comme la découpe des arbres ont débuté
en février notamment sur le terminus à
saint-cyr-l'ecole nos engagements là en
ce moment
des travaux de sondage pour savoir
qu'est ce qui se trouve à l'intérieur de
ce terrain puisque nous allons dès
suspicion de présence de munitions et
donc une fois que ces travaux ces
sondages auront été réalisés nous
commencerons les travaux de terrassement
qui auront lieu jusqu'à l'été ses
premiers travaux devraient durer un an
avant le lancement de la phase
structurel avec l'installation des rails
sur cette partie du terrain et de la
station terminus derrière sept buts dans
sa première partie le tram très express
poursuit le prolongement de la grande
ceinture ouest au nord jusqu'à saint
germain en laye et au sud jusqu'à saint
cyr l'école sont un tracé de 19 km et la
création de six nouvelles gares c'est
vraiment un projet qui permet de mailler
le réseau de permettre des déplacements
à l'intérieur du des plats du
département et donc de faciliter la vie
des yvelinois dans leur département
leurs déplacements quotidiens
la mise en service du tram très express
est prévu après 2020 à terme plus de
vingt mille voyageurs par jour devrait
emprunter cette nouvelle ligne une
information à pratiquer à présent les
déchetteries de saint quentin en
yvelines passe à l'heure d'été
l'ensemble des horaires se trouve sur le
site saint quentin en yvelines point fr
je vous rappelle que le réseau est 17
déchèteries est accessible aux habitants
des douze communes de l'agglomération
sur présentation d'un badge d'accès
elles permettent de déposer gravats bois
déchets verts ou encore encombrants à 18
milles tonnes de déchets ont été
collectés pour l'année 2015
c'est une nouveauté à maurepas seniors
et adolescents qui participent ensemble
à des ateliers ils jouent à des jeux de
société il prépare des recettes de
cuisine elle les anciens donnent des
conseils aux plus jeunes les plus jeunes
qui se passe du temps avec leurs aînés
nous avons suivi l une des rencontres
camille lambert s'appelle
pas un sécateur mais un économe pour la
plupart ces adolescents se mettent en
cuisine pour la première fois leur
mission réaliser des salades de fruits
et des smoothies pour ce faire ils
peuvent compter sur les conseils des
plus anciens comme yannis sous la
direction de brigitte si on écoute la
fraise et qu'après on la met dans l'eau
et malo elle va rentrer dedans et ça
sera placé rarement de la cuisine enfin
je fais pas du tout moi j'ai coupé
banane et pommes on lui a appris à
couper en lamelles il savait pas ce que
c'était les lamelles de couper en
lamelles la banane pour mettre dans le
souci trouve que c'est très bien c'est
ce que je fais avec mes petits enfants
aussi je leur prépare des gâteaux et
voilà des dizaines d'années les séparent
mais ces ateliers sont là pour les
réunir
mise en place en octobre 2016 la ville a
souhaité favoriser le lien inter
générationnel
c'est une ligne qui elle sur le
territoire parmi les deux villes celle
qui a le plus de seniors de plus de 60
en somme un taux de 24 6% et la recette
fait déjà des adeptes
je trouve bien de faire des cuisines de
l'audi
il faut découper comme ça après j'ai
j'ai fait comme ils l'ont fait moi
j'aime beaucoup les jeunes et puis bon
et puis leur apprendre un peu puisque
moi je sais qu'à l'époque ma mère a
montré pont comment il fallait faire
sauf à genia à refaire
ne reste plus qu'à déguster le fruit de
leur labeur prochaine étape faire
pousser les ingrédients avec les beaux
jours des ateliers potager seront
organisées une à deux fois par mois
le lycée hôtelier à guyancourt une
nouvelle fois dans la lumière il
accueille aujourd'hui et demain le
concours du club des directeurs de la
restauration et d'exploitation en france
les candidats ont à peine une vingtaine
d'années il se destine à l'hôtellerie de
luxe mélanie poker c'est un client
mécontent
ces demandes n'ont pas été respectées en
face de lui une candidate qui doit
résoudre la situation
c'est une des épreuves de la finale du
trophée du club des directeurs de la
restauration et d'exploitation c'est
pluridisciplinaire c'est destiné aux
étudiants de bts et de licence des
écoles hôtelières françaises et
monégasque et s'est diffusée sur le
territoire national chaque année sous
forme d'une étude de cas
les sélections se font sur la base d'un
dossier
l'objectif avant tout et pédagogique il
s'agit de
transmettre le goût et l'envié de faire
ce métier qui est un métier très
particulier et aussi pour nous c'est une
occasion de dénicher les véritables
talents
dix candidats sont en lice dans cette
finale à venus de toute la france
mathias guilliers et au lycée de saint
quentin en yvelines pour se qualifier il
a travaillé plus de 300 ha en dehors de
ces études
c'est un travail quotidien ces deux à
trois heures quotidien c'est les
week-ends entiers des vacances parfois
des nuits pour pouvoir mener le projet à
bon terme et puis pour voir faire en
sorte qu'il ressemble à ce qu'on
souhaite juste l'envié la passion de
pouvoir apprendre plus de pouvoir
travailler dans le bon endroit avec un
savoir-faire réel savoir-faire de de
tous les métiers de la restauration le
service la direction la cuisine dix
épreuves attendre les candidats le nom
du vainqueur sera connu vendredi 17 mars
dans la soirée
et bien évidemment nous vous donnerons
les résultats pour savoir si le
guyancourt thouars en compétition a
réussi à s'imposer nous poursuivons avec
du sport à présent et l'école louise
weiss de magny les hameaux qui a eu le
privilège d'accueillir trois joueuses du
club issy paris hand
hier matin une visite pour faire la
promotion du handball féminin mais
surtout du prochain match de championnat
qui opposera leur club à celui et de
brest et qui se déroulera à saint
quentin en yvelines au vélodrome
nationale ce sera le 25 mars prochain
haussmann vendeurs de michael et demi
dans trois stars de l'équipe ici paris
frida techs dead perny wee b et mariam
garba étaient réunis pour faire la
promotion du handball féminin au cm1 de
l'école louise wais une rencontre qui a
fait le bonheur des enfants
bah ça fait du bien de rencontrer des
personnes connues dans le monde entier
et j'en ai jamais vu donc voilà ça fait
plaisir
bah j'en avais jamais vus auparavant et
comme s'agit du handball en sport et par
na na jus des personnes qui savaient
bien échouer la venue des joueuses
étaient aussi l'occasion d'aborder la
question de l'égalité hommes femmes
seul un tiers des 70 mille licenciés de
handball sont des femmes
oui ça c'est très simple pourtant c'est
important d'avoir des jeunes qui
tout commence aujourd'hui en des avoirs
publicité pour notre club c'est
important
issy paris hand affrontera brest le 25
mars au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avec
l'ambition d'attirer plus de 5000
spectateurs record actuel d'affluence à
ce niveau une histoire insolite à
présent un âne ou un surnom qui ne vous
dit peut-être rien et pourtant ce joueur
originaire de madagascar est devenu
champion du monde de pétanque c'était en
décembre 2016 sur son île natale
mais cette histoire est également glay
liée à celle des yvelines le joueur est
licencié au club des clayes-sous-bois
depuis maintenant cinq ans et pour fêter
ce titre est un tournoi a été organisé
le reportage de michael almy dans le
nouveau champion du monde de pétanque
christian andriana ait accueilli en
véritable rock star dans son club des
clayes-sous-bois pour célébrer son titre
glané en décembre dernier les dirigeants
organisent un tournoi au parc jean
carillon pour le sportif de 37 ans
licencié au club depuis 2012 surtout que
moi ont peur parce que déjà compte dans
notés au pays il n'ya pas même un seul
club qui nous a fait l'honneur de nous
prendre dans leurs clubs et tout ça mais
pourtant ici c'est ils ont fait quoi il
faut savoir qu'il y à peu près 50 + 50
états pays qui participent aux
championnats du monde et pour nous c'est
une immense joie que quelque chose
d'inespéré le malgache sur le men à
nouville neuf mois sur douze sur son île
natale et ne revient que trois mois
l'été dans les yvelines pour participer
aux principaux tournois français le lien
du sportif avec les clayes-sous-bois est
avant tout affectif pour pas les clefs
sous bois bat y avait une petite
histoire avait créé avec le président du
club
il y avait
c'était en 2012 il a fait
un tournoi de gala et on l'a gagné et du
coup ils étaient peut-être nous admirer
dans la dent ce temps il a il a eu le
prix de notre peuple
christian driano n'a comme on vous l'a
dit nanou moi je considère un petit peu
comme mon fils c'est vraiment une
immense joie d'avoir un garçon qui allie
la simplicité l'humilité et la
gentillesse et bien sûr l'adresse de la
drees il en faudra encore pour garnir
une nouvelle fois la vitrine du club
nanou participera dès le mois de juillet
au master's et c'est ainsi que nous
refermons à cette édition du journal les
programmes se poursuivent sur téléphiles
les replays sont à consulter sur notre
site internet et sur notre application
mobile à très bientôt sur téléfilm
[Musique]